you probably never notice a tiny jumping  spider in your living room but it is  surely notice you while the arachnids  are famous for their excellent vision  and vibration detection new research  shows that despite their lack of your  drums they can also hear sounds  researchers discover this by putting  tiny electrodes in the sound sensitive  parts of the spiders brains and placing  them on a metal box that canceled out  vibrations from below then they played a  sound at the same frequency as the buzz  of a wasp that preys upon jumping  spiders not only did the spiders freeze  and look around just as they do when  startled in the wild but data from the  electrode showed brain activity spiked  in the auditory area too this shows they  actually hear sounds from a wasp  dive-bombing to you crunching a potato  chip